foreign
[Music]
welcome to today's webinar spatial
single cell characterization of
Alzheimer's disease and mouse and human
hippocampus
I am Matt Ashton of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by nanostring Technologies
to learn more visit nanostring.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send our speakers
will answer any questions via the email
address you provided at the time of
registration you may also submit any
technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
I'd like to not welcome our speakers
Vikram devkin business unit leads
spatial genomics at nanostring
and Miranda Orr assistant professor
gerontology and geriatric medicine Wake
Forest University School of Medicine
Bikram you may now begin your
presentation hello everyone my name is
senior director of product management at
Nano string and cover product portfolio
of geomic DSP as well as Cosmic SMI I'm
really delighted today to talk about our
second spatial platform Cosmic spatial
molecular Imager
Cosmic spatial molecular imager has been
developed to provide High Plex RNA and
protein quantification and visualization
at a single cell resolution in a
morphologically intact tissue
and let me start this uh presentation
with a brief overview of Nano string
the next thing is dedicated to 12
spatial biology biology Solutions
suitable for your such needs
we are the only company with a
comprehensive special ecosystem with
three spatial Solutions
nanosting offers Cosmic platform for
unbiased spatial single cell discoveries
geometric DSP platforms for unbiased
whole transcript term profiling
and atomics as an integrated informatics
portal for both geomix and Cosmic
platforms
both Cosmic and geometric platforms are
backed by Nano strings core competence
of probe design
we have more than excuse me
15 year of experience in probe design
and successful and successfully designed
hundreds of predefined assets panels and
thousands of custom probe across various
species which goes beyond human mouse
and rat
above all Nano sync is a trusted partner
for you we have more than 150 customer
service and support person all over the
globe
the whole job is to support persons uh
to provide you the best customer
experience
no wonder we have over 350 genomic
system installed and over 150
peer-reviewed Publications
now many qls are pre-booking cosmic
platforms as we are getting ready to
ship Cosmic later this year
and when we looked at in a cosmic one of
the main differentiation for Cosmic is
it has the largest panel of any
Institute Imaging platform out there
and that thousand Flags
with thousand plants you have enough
real estate for cell typing genes and
biological path teachings covering cell
State ligand and receptors and more most
informative signaling
I have used Cosmic Mouse Neuroscience
panel as an example here
it includes approximately 250 genes
covering 40 unique cell typing and
approximately 700 genes covering 44
different biological Pathways covering
different biologies all the way from
neuropathology inflammation
neurotransmission
and even after this if we missed your
favorite Gene you can add up up to 50
additional genes into this uh Cosmic
Mouse Neuroscience panel
and actually a lot of work went into
designing these panels
we have a dedicated bioinformatics and
biological content development team for
panel design
and if we look at the whole process of
panel design it can be split into two
parts
first we use data-driven approach for
selecting cell typing specific genes
we use multiple single cell RNA
sequencing data sets with curated cell
types as a as a starting point
and select genes based on their ability
to distinguish one cell type from
another
and the second focus of our panel design
is enriching important biological
pathways
for this we start with curating by
applications
for from key data sets and literature
then we use data driven and text mining
to enrich genes that explain most
variance in each pathways
at the end you will have a panel with
the most relevant theme content for
covering your broad cell typing as well
as biological pathways
in fact Cosmic predefined panels provide
the Best in Class cell typing
here we use Cosmic human Universal RNA
panel to do cell typing with kidney
tissues and compared results with human
cell Atlas kidney data set
and as you can see over here
Cosmic has identified all 33 different
cell types which are identified by human
cell Atlas single cell rna-c data set
and on top of that Cosmic also provides
spatial location for all identified cell
types
in addition Cosmic identified four
different cell types and actually four
different cell subtypes reported by
human selectors
even though these subtypes have very
similar expression profiles
and this is made possible due to the
cosmic proprietary cell typing algorithm
our algorithm approximately weighs the
evidence for all thousand genes and not
just depend upon few marker genes on the
panel
in a spatial location of all identified
four cell subtypes aligns very well with
their assigned biology as shown in this
slide
so let's take an example of a
proliferating proximal to build subtype
it is highlighted here as a red dots so
all the Dots here is a one specific cell
type
and if you focus on the red dots which
are showcasing proliferating proximal
tubule subtypes
this subtype is widespread in a highly
inflamed kidney shown in a leftmost
image
whereas in our rightmost image while it
creating proximal tubules are aligned
with injured ducts
and actually if if we if we take the
overall view of uh Cosmic cell typing
ability
and compare with the Single Cell rnac
Cosmic cell typing actually outperforms
singles are rna-seq cell typing
and we have identified three different
subclusters of my myofibroblast which
was missed by single cell rna-seq
and this is because in addition to the
Thousand genes which we have in our
Cosmic panels
Cosmic algorithm can make use of spatial
context
and cell Imaging data like uh cell size
and amino fluorescent stains
and this overall result is very
impressive uh just consider that Cosmic
resulted in a better cell typing than
single cell rnac data set
and I personally believe that cell
typing is the most fundamental or the
first step in the spatial Institute
platform data analysis
so it is vital to get cell typing done
accurately
and once you have cell typing in place
all other application can be built on
that
like tissue atlasing discovering
function of cell types
understanding impact of neighborhood on
the cell type
influence of cell interaction on disease
progression
or even biomarker Discovery at a single
cell resolution
Cosmic enables all these basic and
translational research application on
the top of accurate cell typing
we are launching Cosmic with a broad
essay menu including multiple thousand
plus RNA panels
and a 64 Flex protein panel
moreover Cosmic comes with a full
customization capability
we you can provide us list of any genes
up to 300 genes and we can build a
custom panel from scratch it's like a
dinova custom panel or you know we are
making a panel you know it's a made to
order custom panel for you
and on top of this you can also
customize our predefined panels you can
add up to any 50 chains to our
predefined panels
so this is more on a customization of
RNA
and we are currently working on a custom
capability of protein and we expect it
to be ready for launch in a mid of next
year that's uh 2023.
so if you look at the cosmic Cosmic is a
complete sample to answer solution with
an integrated and streamlined workflow
sample preparation is based on standard
ish protocol and compatible with both
ffp and fresh frozen sample
after sample prep
you can upload sample to Cosmic
instruments
and Cosmic instrument has an integrated
high resolution microscope for the
readout
so you don't need any additional
instrument all the results or all the
work can be automated on a cosmic
instrument itself and from cosmic data
get transferred directly to a
cloud-based informatics portal called
atomics
for storage for analysis as well as data
sharing
so let's have a look on the cosmic
sample preparation protocol
Cosmic sample preparation take
approximately one and a half day with
three hours Hands-On time
however sample prep can be automated on
a Leica bond which can further reduce
Hands-On time and increase consistency
it's very easy to use there is no tissue
cleaning there is no gel embedding there
is no amplification involved
and after the sample prep you can load
and run up to four slides simultaneously
on a cosmic system
cosmix uses nc2 hybridization chemistry
and the automated psychic Imaging for
the readout
RNA or protein but both the both these
you know biomolecules
Targets in individual cells are
identified through hybridization of
target with specific probes or
antibodies which are labeled with a
unique DNA barcodes as shown here as a
readout domain
and these readout domain is decoded with
cyclic Imaging of fluorescently the
labeled reporter probes
the beauty of cosmic chemistry is Cosmic
needs only up to five targets probe per
Gene and each Target binding domain of
these probes is very short it's just 35
to 50 nucleotides long
and that is why Cosmic work beautifully
with shorter transcript and slightly
degraded RNA including fft samples
during automated cyclic Imaging data get
transferred in a real time to atomics a
cloud-based informatics solution
atomics provide a lot of advantages over
on-prem uh the informatics Solutions
atomics provide comprehensive
visualization and data analysis pipeline
enable compute and storage for large
data outputs
easy data sharing and Global uh
collaboration
SV data sharing and uh and collaboration
is as easy as sending out an email
and Cosmic and atomics comes with an
unmatched security and high cost
effectiveness
and when you look into a you know cost
Effectiveness what we what I mean by
that is with atomics as a cloud-based
service in place you don't ever have to
worry about establishing any ID
infrastructure so there is no upfront
causes involved for buying servers or
auxiliary servers or any part of it
and here is a list of cosmic data houses
pipeline which will be available on
atomics at launch
and these data houses pipeline include
all the way from cell segmentation to
cell typing to Neighborhood analysis to
differential gene expression data
analysis
and above all atomics is an open system
and it empowers you to upload your own
data analysis pipeline to atomics and
thereby it enables any custom analysis
based on your own project so you define
if you want to use some other algorithm
for cell segmentation or you have any
specific data analysis which you would
like to do and you have a date of this
pipeline for that you can upload that on
atomics and use that on atomics itself
I believe that performance of all
spatial Imaging Technologies depend upon
two fundamental attributes
first is spot calling and second is cell
segmentation
Cosmic delivers highly sensitive and
specific spot callings as well as
accurate cell segmentation
Cosmic can detect not only low
expressors well above the background
but also medium expressors and high
expressors as shown over here
it's high dynamic range allows detection
of hundreds to thousands of transcripts
per cell
and here I have shown an example from
non-smalls and lung cancer ffe tissue
and in that in this tissue Cosmic
identified an average of uh 300 pounds
per cell
and maximum of 2500 transcripts per sub
and importantly Cosmic counts show good
correlation with single cell rna-seq
data set as shown here on a left hand
side as well as of with the RNA scope
data set which is shown on the right
hand side
and these comparison further support
Cosmic sensitivity as well as high
specificity
cell segmentation is another important
attribute of cosmics
and Cosmic uses protein Imaging and
machine learning algorithm to deliver
accurate cell segmentation
so this whole process start with focus
stacking uh to of all these 3D images
which we generate like all different Z
stacks and we you know do the focus
stacking of them and generate a very
sharp 2D projection images
and then these images are fed into
nuclear and cytoplasm and membrane uh
you know based Imaging
modules so what we do is in addition to
these images we take uh we use
protein-based Imaging for cytoplasm as
well as for cell membrane and then we do
a nucleus staining and all these images
are fed into our cell segmentation
modules uh nuclear modules provide a one
output cytoplasmic module provide
another output which we merged together
and these and combine into a final cell
segmentation output as shown over here
and as a result you get a very precise
cell boundary detection
here are few representative example uh
highlighting robust cell segmentation
across different tissues
from your fresh frozen Mouse brain to
ffp uh human colon human press as well
as human skin tissues and we have done
this for more than 15 different tissues
with a very good and accurate self
segmentation
so so far uh you know I talked about
Cosmic RNA capability
but RNA is not the whole world uh
actually protein is equally important in
fact both RNA and protein analysis is
required to get a comprehensive tissue
analysis
iplex RNA Shield detailed molecular
function but as you can see here you
need High Flex protein Imaging for
absolute tissue architecture analysis
and Cosmic provides both High Flex RNA
as well as high Flex protein analysis at
a single cell down to a subcellular
resolution
we are launching Cosmic with 64 Flex
human immuncology protein panel and this
uh human IO panel cover most relevant
proteins from different biology all the
way from your these cells biology to T
Cell Biology to checkpoint biology
and our plan is to expand as a routine
as a menu with mouse Neuroscience panel
and I also add customization capability
by the mid of next year
Cosmic protein panel goes through a
vigorous antibody validation process
and these processes include pre and post
conjugation in digital ISC validation
followed by validation as a combined
panel to check interference and the
performance of the all 64 different
antibodies by a trained a in-house
pathologists
and these antibody validation process
ensures High sensitivity as well as
specificity for Cosmic protein panels
as of today human IO protein panel has
been tested and validated for its use
across multiple tissues including lymph
nodes press and colon and then
a few more listed at the bottom of this
slide and we are keep testing it with
the more tissues to make them compatible
with our Cosmic protein panels
so just do some rice uh uh overall
the cosmic system
delivered researchers the ability to
detect more genes than any other
Institute system with a large fan of
thousand genes
Cosmic has multi-ohmic capability with
high plaques RNA I will say highest plus
RNA and high Flex protein content which
is optimized to work across variety of
sample types including fresh frozen and
ffp
its throughput is really scalable you
can go all the way from 2 to 20 slides
per week based upon your research needs
as well as
can you can analyze the whole tissue
section in a just one single run we have
Cosmic has a scan area of 300 millimeter
square and then hold and on top of this
you can get a very high resolution
actually a sub cellular resolution
Cosmic has X and Y resolution of around
50 nanometer and these resolution of a
couple of hundred nanometers
but if you look at all these uh
specifications
these are Best in Class product
specification
but for Cosmic it is just a big name
we we are going to improve this even
further as uh with the time
and currently uh our we are focusing on
two major things one is Plex another is
throughput
and we will provide more update on these
parameters which will be improved on
what we already have at agbt which is
approximately you know in four months
from now but keep in mind there is not
going to be any change on a hardware uh
these new capabilities in terms of
increasing our flat and throughput is
only through the assets and chemistry
part
thanks everyone for your time and now I
will pass this on to miranda.org she has
a very interesting story with both
geomix and cosmics uh platform so now
let's hear from amaring hour
well thank you so much for that
introduction I'm really excited to be
here with you some of the research from
my lab where we've been using special
single cell characterization of
Alzheimer's disease in both Mouse and
human brain
I'd like to thank the funding for my lab
and in particular the project that I'm
going to be talking about today is
funded by an r01 from the National
Institute on Aging by co-investigators
are Dr Dirk Keane at the University of
Washington who has provided all the
postmortem human brain for this study Dr
habil Zer at UT Health in San Antonio
who is providing bioinformatics support
Tim Orr in my lab has run all the
geometrics digital spatial profiling
that I'm going to share and Shiva
dakordi is a talented graduate student
in the Zara Lab at UT Health who is also
providing bioinformatics support
I'd also like to thank the amazing team
at nanostring for helping us with the
spatial molecular Imaging that I'll be
sharing
so over the next 45 minutes or so I'm
going to be talking about Alzheimer's
disease and my lab's approach to
tackling this very devastating and
challenging disorder
then we're going to shift to using
geometrics digital spatial profiling to
analyze postpartum human Alzheimer's
disease brain and then talk about the
Next Generation nanostring instrument
Cosmic spatial molecular imager where
we're profiling Mass models of
neurodegeneration and then at the end
share a little sneak peek of some of the
cosmic data we've generated on human
brain
Alzheimer's disease is the most common
cause of dementia in older adults more
than 6 million Americans are living with
Alzheimer's disease and by 2050 this
number is projected to rise to nearly 13
million
it's lethal there are no disease
modifying treatments and one in three
seniors dies with Alzheimer's disease or
another type of dementia and to put that
into perspective it kills more than
breast cancer and prostate cancer
combined
age is the number one risk factor but
what research is showing is that 20
years or even more before the symptoms
brain changes associated with
Alzheimer's disease may be occurring
in 2016 the National Institute on aging
and Alzheimer's Association defined
Alzheimer's Disease by its biology so
using the ATN framework for a stands for
amyloid beta this is a cleavage protein
from a larger protein called amyloid
precursor protein and a beta accumulates
outside of the cells and plaques T
stands for Tau Tau is a microtubule
Associated protein that accumulates as
neurofibrillary Tangles inside of
neurons and n stands for
neurodegeneration so shown here on the
is an image of our brain on the left is
a healthy brain and on the right is an
advanced Alzheimer's disease brain so
you can see the dramatic brain atrophy
enlargement of ventricles and the the
shrinkage of certain brain regions that
are largely due to a loss of neurons
but as I pointed out age is the number
one misread risk factor for developing
Alzheimer's disease and my lab is really
trying to understand the connection
between Advanced age and Alzheimer's
disease how is it that this black box of
Aging can take a young healthy brain and
through the course of a lifespan turn it
into a dysfunctional tissue for this our
team relies on the biology of Aging
fields and in this field of study
research has have identified
cellular and molecular processes that
not only co-occur with aging but
actually drive the aging process if
their return they can accelerate aging
and dry pathology and if they're
intervened upon they can delay aging
pathologies and improve healthy lifespan
when we've identified something that we
think may be relevant to Alzheimer's
disease the next step is to determine if
there's evidence in people for this we
use postmortem human brain tissue or
analyze publicly available data sets
when we find evidence in people then we
can take this back to the lab and test
interventions in mice if these
interventions improve cognition and
brain Imaging then we move this to
clinical trial
and in my lab we are focused on
Tau as a driver of cellular senescence
which is a Hallmark of Aging that I will
talk about in this presentation we've
found evidence of senescent neurons in
post-mortem human brain and when we've
cleared senescent cells in transgenic
mice we've improved brain structure and
function so we've now moved to a
clinical trial
so now what we're doing is using new
technologies to really profile this
neuropathology and Alzheimer's disease
to better understand how tau is driving
senescence and what cells may be best
targeted by these catalytic Therapies
so in Alzheimer's disease using this ATN
framework amyloid beta is tracked by
what is called fall phase and that just
tells us where in the brain these
plaques are and tau is tracked by what
is referred to as Brock stage and
similarly this tells us where in the
brain these these Tangles are but it
doesn't tell us anything about the
molecular makeup of plaques and tangles
in my lab we're particularly interested
in the Tau containing neurofibility
Tangles that is because they more
closely track with disease progression
that implies however not all individuals
with neuropathology have dementia that
means that some people have normal
cognition but when they come to autopsy
there is evidence of plaques and tangles
in their brain and so we're asking a
very simple question are all Tangles the
same or perhaps we can subtype them
based on their molecular signature
to do this we're using nanostrains
geometrics digital spatial profiling and
in this slide I've provided an overview
of the technology and essentially the
first step is like any other
histological assay where you stay in the
tissue using your morphology markers and
along with these morphology markers you
add UV you add fluorescent antibodies or
RNA scope probes depending if you're
looking at protein or RNA and these are
linked with UV photo cleavable oligos
you select your regions of Interest or
areas of interest on your tissue that
you want to profile then using UV light
you cleave these photo clickable all of
those so these are barcodes that then
get collected and dispense into a
multi-welt plate and then they're
counted either with nanostering
platforms or sequenced where you can
look at proteins or up to the whole
transcriptome and because this is a
non-destructive method you can map all
of these measures back to your tissue of
Interest so shown here here is a post
word of human brain and we are looking
at neurons in the enter rhinocortex and
the ca1 of the hippocampus and the
reason is that these are regions that
are prone to develop Tangles early in
Brock stage moreover they are
synaptically connected so we can profile
these neurons and see how they may be
interacting or how their molecular
profiles change
and for this our morphology marker is
ATA which is a antibody that detects
neurofability angles and throughout this
presentation I'm going to be using this
marker so the magenta marks the tangle
we're also profiling neighboring neurons
without tingles from the same brain
region
in the particular data set that I'm
about to share we have Quantified 95
proteins that span neural neural cell
types glial cell types neuropathology
and protein kinase pathways
so shown here is a volcano plot where we
have compared tangle bearing neurons on
the right to non-tangle bearing neurons
on the left so anything up on the right
is higher in a tangle bearing neuron and
anything up on the left is higher in a
non-tangle bearing neuron but I'm going
to point your attention to are these top
four proteins that are most
significantly differentially expressed
between these two cell types
three of the four are phosphorylated Tau
now that may not be groundbreaking we do
know that Tangles accumulate
phosphorylated Tau but to us this was a
confirmation that the technology was
working similarly it it provides
evidence that in our panel
phosphorylated Tau might be the most
differentially expressed proteins
between these two cell types but what
we're really interested in is
heterogeneity in neurofibrillary Tangles
so shown here is a heat map of 324 ca1
neurons with Tangles from 11 cases of
dementia aged 50 to 100 years old each
column is an individual neuron and each
row is an individual protein and so I
think what you can appreciate from this
heat map is there is some heterogeneity
now I'd like to guide your attention to
this purple band near the middle this is
phosphorylated Tau and you can see
there's heterogeneity here as well this
is interesting to us because our prior
work found a close overlap between
neurons of Tangles and cellular
senescence which is a fundamental
cellular aging stress response
in this cartoon I have depicted a neuron
undergoing this or a cell undergoing
this complex stress response called
cellular senescence so this cell in the
middle that's green is you can think of
this as a damaged cell and it is not
able to repair this damage but it
doesn't die and it doesn't continue to
divide but instead it undergoes
senescence this is a change in sulfate
where the cell actually changes its
morphology it upregulates both
pro-survival and pro-impoptotic Pathways
so it is stuck alive
the only way that it can be cleared is
if it is cleared by the immune system so
it releases molecules that signal the
immune system to clear it but if the
immune system doesn't receive this
message these pro-inflammatory cytokines
and chemokines can damage the
neighboring tissue killing these cells
or transforming them to become senescent
so we wondered whether or not Tangles
may be senescent because we know that
neurons with Tangles closely track with
disease progression
neurofibrillary tangle containing
neurons survive predicted up to 20 years
in the brain
yet neuron loss bar exceeds number of
Tangles by orders of magnitude
so the first step
we used a hypothesis-driven approach
where we compare neurons and Tangles to
non-tangle bearing neurons in the same
brain and we published this in 2018 so
I'm not going to spend too much time
going over it but we did find if we just
focused our neurons with or without
Tangles neurons of Tangles had a
senescent phenotype
but we wanted to use an unbiased screen
and more broadly look at all cell types
in the brain and at that time the only
technology available to do that was
single nucleus RNA sequencing so we
looked at 140 000 cells from 76 brains
with different levels of Alzheimer's
disease neuropathology and used four
embryonic brains as controls
and we created Gene lists that reflect
different aspects of the senescent
stress response so the initial stress
response was covered by 44 genes the
stable cell cycle arrest was covered by
22 genes and the inflammatory response
or the secretory phenotype was covered
by 48 genes
and when we asked these 140 000 cells
which of you are expressing these
phenotypes we found about two percent
expressed each of these Pathways and
when we asked which of which cells are
these we found that over 97 percent of
these senescent cells were excitatory
neurons and they overlapped with tangles
using our canonical stress response
signature we asked what is the gene that
is contributing most to this response
and we found cdk and 2D and then for the
next step we wanted to confirm whether
or not we found this in tissue
so in collaboration with Dr Rachel
Bennett from MGH she performed RNA scope
where in this image the yellow are
neurons and the white rcdk and 2D
transcript and we found that cdk n2d was
highly expressed in neurons
and then Jamie walked Dr Jamie Walker
who was at UT Health in San Antonio and
is now at Mount Sinai performed p19
histology so cdk n2d codes the protein
p19 and when she stained uh brains
Alzheimer's disease compared to controls
she saw upregulated p19 in Alzheimer's
for our next step we did Cove for a
sensor co-staining and so Dr Bennett
co-stained these tissues for Tangles
which are shown in red in the cdkn2d
probe which are shown in white and so
close our strong overlap between cdk and
n2d and neurons of Tangles
similarly when we did
co-immunofluorescence in our lab where
we stained tangles in yellow and p19 in
magenta we saw overlap
so this was really exciting that our
bioinformatics predicted a marker that
we could then use and add into our
profiling method so now in addition to
using at8 in our geomax profiling we've
added p19 so now we're profiling four
different types of cells neurons that
have ATI ATA and magenta with or without
p19 and green it runs with only p19 and
green and neurons that don't have p19 or
ATA is shown here is a heat map of the
of an experiment where we profile these
four different types of cells I'd like
to draw your attention to the right side
of the heat map so the green column are
neurons of Tangles and the blue column
are neurons of Tangles that also have
the senescent marker so these are
considered these would both be
considered t plus with traditional Brock
staging but now we've identified a
subtype that is t plus senescence and
what we see if I draw your attention to
the middle purple band this is
phosphorylated Tau so you can see
there's High Tau phosphorylation in both
but when we look at other proteins there
are significant difference where the
neuron with the tangle that also has a
p19 marker looks a lot more like the
healthy cells without the tangle than
than the neurons with the tangles so our
next question was does this uh
heterogeneity heterogeneity and tingles
have any functional implications
and for this I again collaborated with
Dr Jamie Walker and we compared brains
that had the similar box had similar
Brock stages meaning they had similar
level of tangle burden but some
individuals had cognitive impairment and
some individuals had normal cognition
and what we found is in the individuals
resilient to this pathology they had
lower phosphotal at 396 and 404 and they
had higher levels of synaptic protein
expression lower inflammation and lower
oxidative and energetic stress
suggesting not only is there
heterogeneity and Tangles but it
actually may have functional
implications
we're now moving into a next generation
of Technology called Cosmic spatial
molecular Imaging also developed by
nanostream so with this technology we
get subcellular resolution of these
analytes
and the data that I'm about to share
were done in collaboration with a
fantastic team at nanostream led by Lee
Don Wu
for the initial spatial molecular
Imaging experiment we focused on Mouse
brain so shown here I have Mouse brains
below the human brains and in the same
orientation where the healthy mouth
spring or wild type Mouse is on the left
and the Tau transgenic or disease is on
the right and you can appreciate the
Hermetic brain atrophy that occurs in
these transgenic mice and for this
experiment we used a 1003 Plex RNA panel
that spans cell typing and mapping genes
all the way through regulatory signaling
in this experiment generated amazing
fantastic data and I'm just going to
give you a little snapshot of what we
found so first using supervised cell
typing we identified 42 different cell
types and one undefined cluster
as clustering we identified 42 cell
types but when they are mapped back to
the brain we have high confidence in
these cell types and their local
resolution or their location within the
brain because we know that neurons are
where neurons should be in the gray
matter and we have microglia where we
know microglia are we have
oligodendrocytes where we know myelin is
we then condense these cell types into
more broad categories to get a broader
comparison between the wild hype and Tau
transgenic so in this graph we have the
different cell types the taller the bar
the more cells there are and when we
compare this wild type mounts to a Tau
transgenic we can see noticeable
differences that are predicted based on
this model so for example the Red Bar
are neurons we see far fewer in the Tau
transgenic the orange bar on the far
left are astrocytes and we do know that
Tau transgender do accumulate astrocytes
or have astrosychosis so again this
gives us confidence with the method
what is really powerful about this this
technology is because we know
differential gene expression in cell
types and where all of these cell types
are located we can now identify spatial
niches so shown here are spatial niches
of wildlife mice and if we compare that
to the Tau transgenic you can see these
dramatic differences in fact the Tau
transgenic Mouse is missing three
spatial niches and we know what cell
types are in these niches for example in
spatial Niche two and five which are
which are significantly lower or missing
in the child transgenic these niches are
comprised largely of neurons
and again because we know differential
gene expression and where these cells
are located we now get spatial
differentially expressed Gene in each
cell type and can make these Maps so
shown here is an example of microglia
and this is a lot of data in a busy
slide and I only want to show you this
as an example so on the y-axis are
individual genes and on the x-axis our
comparison between meshes so if we look
at microglia and compare different
niches we can see how each Niche either
upregulates or down regulates that
particular Gene and we can compare
between genotypes so as an example we'll
just look at apoe so for example in the
wild type Mouse apoe is enriched in
Niche 9 versus Niche one and seven but
it's depleted in each one and seven
versus Niche 6. and then we compare that
to what happens in Tau transgenic
so until transgenic apoe is also
enriched in the schnine versus Niche one
but is depleted in Niche 3 versus Niche
1 and 6. 6 and again we have this or
this level of data across all cell types
another really powerful aspect of this
technology is that we're able to look at
multiple transcripts at cellular and
subcellular resolution
so in the previous work where we were
looking to identify senescent cells in
single nucleus RNA sequencing now we're
essentially using that same approach but
looking at it in a tissue so these
different Gene panels listed here are
the same genes that we use for the
single nucleus RNA sequencing and the
white boxes that I have highlighted are
ca1 neurons and if we compare wild type
to Tau transgenic
we can now look at these gene expression
signatures within individual cells and
zoom in and really ask the question are
these cells senescent are they
expressing the gene signatures that give
us confidence in identifying these cells
as senescent or not
more recently if we've been working with
nanostrain and many of the same team
members to apply this technology to
formally fixed paraffin embedded
postmortem human brain
so something that I haven't highlighted
yet but is just incredible about this
technology is you get a morphological
image of the entire tissue and you can
zoom in a subcellular resolution so
shown here in this morphology scan
histone is in blue gfap to measure or to
Mark astrocytes is in red 18s RNA is in
green and ATA for Tangles is in yellow
and then we can zoom in and look at
transcripts in each of these cells
so similar to some of our proof of
concept experiments using geomix we've
done the same thing with spatial
molecular Imaging in postmark membrane
so shown here are blue transcripts of
immediate early genes that is in the
cyan color and these genes are
transcribed in neurons when they are
they are active and so we're focused on
dentate gyrus neurons in both healthy
and Alzheimer's disease and looking for
these transcripts and in magenta are
growth factors and in green are
transcription factors that would drive
expression of these and if we zoom in
what is really incredible is if we look
at the healthy tissue the health
identity gyro cells we see immediate
early gene expression we see growth
factor expression but when we look in
the Alzheimer's disease we don't so this
again is somewhat expected we know that
the density driver cells are really
important in learning in memory and in
Alzheimer's disease these functions are
impaired
so now that we have confidence in this
technology we can begin to ask questions
about gene expression that we think may
be relevant to Alzheimer's disease and
aging so on this slide I'm showing
autophagy genes in cyan and lysosomal
genes in magenta we know that there is
proteostasis disruptions in Alzheimer's
disease and if we compare healthy on top
to Alzheimer's disease on bottom you can
see a dramatic reduction in the
transcription and if we zoom in we have
healthy now on the left and Alzheimer's
disease on the right
compared to the healthy that have high
transcription or hygiene expression of
autophagy and lysosomal genes in
Alzheimer's disease we don't see the
same patterns except for if we look at
neurons or Tangles so in this we've now
co-stained for the tangle marker in
yellow and we see that this particular
neuron does have high lysosomal and
autophagy gene expression similar to the
healthy controls so again this is
suggesting that these neurons though
they are incredibly stressed with this
tangle they are surviving
so just to summarize and provide some
insights into some of our future
directions we are finding that senescent
cells accumulate in Alzheimer's disease
and neurons of neurofibrillary tables
are primary source of senescent cells
and Alzheimer's disease
using geometrics digital spatial
profiling we're now able to reveal
heterogeneity across these tangles
and this heterogeneity is partially
explained by senescence and it has
functional implications on dementia
status
then moving to Cosmic spatial molecular
Imaging we're now able to to use
subcellular profiling to look inside
these brain cell types we're going to
use this to inform our brain changes
with age and neurodegeneration both in
mice and humans
so in conclusion spatial profiling
Technologies are significantly advancing
Neuroscience research and in particular
Alzheimer's disease research and for
translational neurobiologists like
myself
that requires species flexibility we're
able to profile both Mouse and human
brains
rate the technology is compatible with
Frozen nffpe tissue
we're able to look at multiple analytes
I showed evidence of both multiple
transcripts as well as Multiplex protein
expression
and what's really powerful is that we
get tissue level analyzes as well as
subcellular resolution
so now we're able to look at this in
multiple cell types multiple brain
regions neighborhoods especially
specially resolved gene expression
across tissues cells and niches
so with that I would like to acknowledge
my team at Wake Forest my lab as I
mentioned earlier Tim Orr is running all
the geomix experiments in the lab again
Dr Dirk Keen is providing all the
postmortem human brain tissue and Dr
Zaire and his student Sheba are
providing bioinformatics support Dr
Jamie Walker I mentioned has provided
neuropathology support as well and I'd
like to thank the nanostring team for
helping with the spatial molecular
Imaging and I didn't mention but Dr bin
Zang and Pang Zhu at Mount Sinai are
providing bioinformatics support as well
thank you so much for your time
thank you Vikram and Miranda for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor nanostring Technologies
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
questions will be addressed by the
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
libraries will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye